اذا هو هدون حذر يشهده السودان بعد موافقه
الطرفين النزاع على تمديد الهدنه
الانسانيه الاثنتين وسبعين ساعه اضافيه مع
ذلك شهدت العاصمه الخرطوم بعد الخروق
للهدنه حيث تحدث مراسم الجزيره عن سماع
تحليق للطائرات فضلا عن انفجارات
واشتباكات بالاسلحه المتوسطه والخفيفه
شهدها محيط القصر الجمهوري ومركز الخرطوم
كما شاهد الضحيه الشماليه الخرطوم بحري
اشتباكات واطلاق نار باسلحه خفيفه وثقيله
وفقا لما فاز به مراسل الجزيره
ووسط هذه الاجواء قال الجيش السوداني ان
الاوضاع مستقره في جميع ولايه السودان
مضيفا في بيان ان رصده لتحركات ما سماه
العدو يؤكد استمرار محاوله الاخير تعزيز
موقفه على الارض وانه مستمر في التصديلها
واشار البيان لان قوات الجيش تمكنت من خفض
قدرات العدو القتاليه بنسبه تتراوح بين 45
الى 55 بالمئه واكد انه لا يسمح بان تقوم
اي تشوهات في البنيه العسكريه للبلاد
مجددا وفق تعبيره وقال بيان الجيش ان
البلاد ورثه
النظام البائد الاستراتيجي بتكوين ميليشيا
الدعم السريع وفقام جاء في البيان